Movies have been made in Hollywood since it
was incorporated into the city of Los Angeles
in 1910.
These early flicks often featured military
equipment in the background, such as for an
air show.
Nonetheless, prior to granting access to its
assets, the military ensured that each scene
and film reflected its values and presented
its soldiers in a positive way.
As the nation entered the great wars, the
need to project American power and resolve
became paramount.
Also satisfying the public’s desire for
high quality entertainment, military advisers
helped film industry professionals make realistic,
yet positive, films to support war efforts
for both World War I and World War II.
In the lull between the two conflicts, the
relationship between Hollywood and the military
became fixed with the 1927 flick, Wings.
With a cast that included 3,000 infantry and
featuring U.S. planes (and pilots flying them)
in the backdrop of a story of two pilots trying
to win the “it” girl, Clara Bow, Wings
not only won the Best Picture Oscar that year,
but it showed how cooperation between the
corps and Hollywood provided huge benefits
to both: Hollywood created an authentic military
experience and enjoyed commercial and critical
success, and the military had what for them
was essentially a great recruitment film displayed
in theaters across the country.
During and after World War II, Hollywood war
movies nearly universally featured brave men
whose causes always succeeded even if they
perished, and notable titles included: They
Were Expendable (1945), Sands of Iowa Jima
(1949), The Flying Leathernecks (1951), Stalag
17 (1953), The Bridges at Toko-Ri (1954),
The Longest Day (1962) and The Great Escape
(1963).
Likewise, films like From Here to Eternity
(1953), Mister Roberts (1955), South Pacific
(1958) and Operation Petticoat (1959) put
a positive human face on the war and its servicemen.
And it is precisely this human face that led
author Lawrence Suid to coin the phrase “mutual
exploitation.”
According to Suid:
When I was getting my film degree it suddenly
occurred to me that people in the U.S. had
never seen the U.S. lose a war, and when President
Johnson said we can go into Vietnam and win,
they believed him because they’d seen 50
years of war movies that were positive.
So important was this relationship that since
the middle of the century, the Pentagon has
had a permanent liaison stationed in Hollywood,
and until 1989, that man was Donald Baruch.
Having earned his chops as a theater producer
in New York, Baruch was given final script
approval on movies that needed military equipment
and personnel, and he asserted his authority.
He insisted that the image projected of the
armed forces and its men be clean-cut and
upright.
After four decades at the post, Baruch was
replaced by Phil Strub, who had studied film
at the University of Southern California,
before developing a specialty in making movies
of medical procedures.
He eventually made his way into the Army’s
medical research unit and worked as a Navy
videographer before moving into the entertainment
liaison post.
Today, however, Strub is not alone in sifting
through scripts to determine which past muster.
Service members from each branch are now stationed
in Los Angeles where they spend their days
studying television and film scripts, including
for shows like NCIS and Hawaii Five-O. Together
with Strub and the upper brass, their contributions
include everything from pitching ideas to
ensuring the right equipment is employed.
For example, the Secretary of the Navy was
reported to have persuaded NCIS to do an episode
on that branch’s efforts to stop sexual
assault.
Likewise, Strub has claimed that he convinced
the producers of Jurassic Park III to re-write
their script to remove use of the Thunderbolt
warplane, (A-10), which was so overpowering
that in Strub’s estimation, it would have
“only generated sympathy for the dinosaurs.”
Of course, many war movies are made without
military help, and while some titles should
be expected, like Apocalypse Now (1979) and
The Thin Red Line (1998), others may be more
of a surprise.
For example, help with Independence Day (1996)
was nixed because the invading alien’s overwhelming
technological superiority made the “military
appear impotent and/or inept.”
As a result, its battle equipment was produced
with methods such as CGI, as were some of
the military crew in Zero Dark Thirty (2012).
It should be noted that although the military
gains a huge benefit from its positive portrayal
in films, it doesn’t spend any extra taxpayer
money on these projects.
If the producers are directing personnel and
equipment outside of normal operations, they
pay the costs of operation (which can range
from $1,000/hour for a tank to $25,000/hour
for an F-15).
However, if all they want to do is film typical
activity that was happening anyway, once approved,
they can do that gratis.
Nonetheless, this is still a huge benefit
for movie-makers, who avoid the cost of CGI,
purchasing and leasing actual equipment and
Screen Actors Guild (SAG) minimum rates, since
“even in an age of special effects, it’s
exponentially cheaper to
film on actual military ships with real military
advisers.”